dans la région du xinjiang nord ouest a
chine une mère de famille dit avoir été
sommé de se rendre au poste de police du
coin zoomera djaout une membre de la
minorité musulmane ouïghoure affirme
avoir été menotté et cagoulés elle dit
avoir fait le trajet d'une heure dans un
véhicule sans savoir où on en est cordon
rouge ils m'ont mise dans l'auto je
pensais qu'ils allaient mener sur une
montagne et me tirer dans le dos et dit
avoir été enfermé pendant des mois dans
un camp d'internement comme celui ci à
l'insu de son épouse de ses enfants
selon les nations unies plus d'un
millions de ouïghours ont été interdits
dans de tels camps la chine ni qu'il
s'agit de camps d'internement de sa
collègue chris noth mais une fuite de
documents confidentiels du gouvernement
chinois obtenu par le consortium
international des journalistes enquête
dévoile les plans secrets pékin un vaste
système de détention pour
l'endoctrinement d'un peuple minoritaire
genève
[Musique]
début novembre sur la rive sud de
montréal des ouigours se rassemblent
pour une soirée festive
ils sont près de 2000 à vivre au canada
[Musique]
derrière les danses et les sourires
plusieurs n'ont pas le coeur à la fête
l'angoissé la porte taille cette
communauté les gens innocents rapport il
peut plus parler de rien ils tuent leurs
grandes choses sur toi harkis aliev est
d'origine ouïghoure
il a émigré à montréal avec ses parents
il ya 20 ans ils sont inquiets car ils
n'arrivent plus à joindre les membres de
leurs familles qui vivent en chine quand
on les appelle sur les téléphones en
ligne irène bath à son poste on n'arrive
pas à les rejoindre
qu'est-ce qui en est avec mes frères mes
soeurs qu'est ce qui a amené avec les
cousins des cousines mais ces gens là
ont disparu comme s'ils n'ont jamais
existé on a aucun signe de vie depuis
déjà plusieurs années
[Musique]
plus de 10 millions de ouïghours vivent
dans la région de xinjiang dans
l'extrême nord ouest de la chine
cette région et chant pétrole et en
ressources minières est stratégique pour
la chine pour assurer son
approvisionnement énergétique et pour
établir de nouvelles voies commerciales
vers l'occident
les ouigours sont une minorité
turcophone et musulmane depuis longtemps
victime de discrimination aux mains de
la majorité chinoise ran
[Musique]
les tensions entre les deux groupes
ethniques ont mené à des émeutes et des
attentats commis par des ouïghours pékin
a réagi avec force au nom de la lutte
contre le séparatisme et le terrorisme
les autorités chinoises ont rendu
inégale de nombreuses pratiques
religieuses les prénoms comme mohamed
fatima sont interdits pour les nouveaux
nés
même le port de la barbe est proscrit la
langue ouïgoure est interdite dans les
écoles
la chine et la politique chinoise essaie
d'éliminer les plus sains en gohelle à
leur religion donc écouté tout
simplement pour pour complètement leur
est facile à là la culture ouïgoure la
culture musulmane
pékin cherche à assimiler les ouigours
au sein de la culture chinoise dominante
selon la professeure vanessa franceville
donc l'idée aujourd'hui si on suit le
discours chinois c'est que pour
stabiliser la région il faut éduquer
neutraliser une certaine partie de la
population et donc cette population elle
est majoritairement ouïghour
[Musique]
en 2016 la répression s'est accru de
façon marquée avec la mise en place d'un
redoutable appareil de surveillance
les caméras sont partout les
applications espionne le contenu des
téléphones cellulaires et grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle les
policiers analysent toutes ces données
pour suivre à la trace
une population entière
marcher sur la lune déjà les ordinateurs
peuvent coopérer votre face et avoir
toute l'information nécessaire dans
leurs fichiers donc sauvé en 184 sol y
aller elle est venue à tout les points
que ce soit le métro ça soit les centre
commercial vous rentrez laeken
empreintes digitales je crois qu'il faut
aussi voir la région ouigours comme une
région laboratoire
on est en train de mettre en place une
société dystopique à la george orwell
grâce aux données recueillies par
l'appareil de surveillance les policiers
ont ciblé des centaines de milliers de
ouïghours et dans bien des cas on les a
appréhendés pour avoir posé des gestes
anodins est associée à des pratiques
religieuses selon vanessa franceville
dans cette liste vous avez à la fois le
jeune la prière le refus de boire de
l'alcool le refus de fumer des
cigarettes mais vous avez aussi le fait
d'avoir installé un vpn sur votre
téléphone
whatsapp pour communiquer avec votre
famille à l'étranger
une fois arrêtés les ouigours sont
envoyés dans des camps d'internement
pour les reprogrammer
ils doivent abandonner leur pratique
religieuse et effectuer des travaux
manuels
selon l'onu plus d'un million d'entre
eux ont été internés c'est plus de 10 %
de leur population la chine ni
catégoriquement mener une campagne de
répression contre les membres de cette
minorité ethnique hinsingen il se fout
les risques lorsque confronté par nos
collègues la bbc la semaine dernière
l'ambassadeur de chine à londres a
affirmé que les camps ne sont que de
simples écoles de métiers pour des
jeunes qui auraient commis des fautes
mineures
19h15 a ajouté je prends de sa faux
mails et documents secrets obtenus par
le consortium international des
journalistes d' enquêtes confirment
qu'il s'agit bel et bien de camp de
détention extrajudiciaire
ce document confidentiel datant de 2010
est signé et approuvé par le numéro deux
du parti communiste au xinjiang
zhu hailun dévoilé directives pour
améliorer le fonctionnement de ces camps
on y parle entre autres de l'importance
de prévenir les évasions en améliorant
les tours de guet et en verrouillant les
portes des dortoirs et des corridors à
double tour des responsables des camps
sont sommés de contrôler les activités
des détenus pour empêcher les évasions
pendant les classes les repas les pauses
toilettes et les douches
on y décrit les méthodes
d'endoctrinement où l'on évalue par un
système de pointage la transformation
idéologique des détenus et leur respect
de la discipline
nous avons montré ces documents à
vanessa franqueville ça révèle une toute
autre réalité que ce que la chine veut
nous faire croire et ça révèle un écart
important entre ce qu'il se passe de
façon officielle dans les documents qui
sont partagés entre les fonctionnaires
et ce qui est distribué aux audiences
internationales la fuite montre
également que le système de surveillance
dachine ci est aussi à l'oeil des
ouigours de nationalité étrangère
ce document mentionne que cinq canadiens
d'origine ouigours se trouvait en visite
en chine en juin 2017 et que leur
dossier devait être examinée de près par
les préfectures
donc ça veut dire qu'il y avait déjà une
surveillance importante sur les ouigours
à l'étranger ce qui est déjà quelque
part inquiétant parce que ce sont des
citoyens non chinois c'est des citoyens
canadiens sur l'ambassadeur de chine à
londres rejettent la véracité de
documents qui laisserait entendre que la
chine a mis sur pied des camps
d'internement
le temps commence au poteau mais
l'authenticité de ces documents a été
confirmée par plusieurs experts et des
témoignages bouleversants d'ex-détenus
décrivent l'enfer des camps
d'internement
on voyait de nos propres yeux des choses
horrifiante ce ne sont pas des êtres
humains à des milliers de kilomètres de
la chine un jeune diplômé de la faculté
de droit de l'université de colombie
britannique a décidé de mener sa propre
enquête pour dénombrer les mystérieux
camps d'internement dans son pays
d'origine
armé d'un simple ordinateur portable il
a découvert sur des sites officiels
chinois
des appels d'offres liés à la
construction des camps
[Musique]
cet appel d'offres a été publié en avril
2010 est la construction de ce camp a
commencé en mai 2017
on voit des miradors sur les images
satellites à partir des ombrages on voit
qu'il s'agit de mirador comme dans une
prison
il y en a quatre ici fort à faire les
images satellite révèlent aussi
l'installation de clôtures et de
barbelés scolaire il s'agit d'un vaste
projet presque toutes les villes du
xinjiang ont un compte ce genre
il dit l'avoir trouvée jusqu'à
maintenant environ une centaine de camps
d'internement dont il publie les détails
sur internet ce qui ne fait pas les
affaires des autorités chinoises et de
paris mais à ma recherche me met dans
une situation très difficile mais je me
considère chanceux si je me compare à
mes amis ouigours je suis chinois de la
majorité anh je ne risque pas ma vie en
m'exprimant ici la publication de preuve
irréfutable comme ces images satellites
ont forcé les autorités chinoises a
changé leur discours et à admettre
l'existence des camps
on est passé de cela n'existe pas oui
cela existe jusqu'à et d'ailleurs c'est
très très bien suivez notre modèle
puisque aujourd'hui la chine ventes
ces écoles comme des modèles pour le
reste du monde
la chine a même invité des journalistes
et des experts étrangers à visiter
quelques-uns des camps en août dernier
l'historien canado albanais aussi yasi a
participé à une de ses visites guidées
il a tourné ces images avec son
téléphone je suis allé un terrain de
sport et j'ai vu des garçons ouigours en
train de jouer j'ai voulu les
interviewer mais on me l'a interdit
on leur montre des jeunes qui semblent
s'amuser mais en vérité tout est
soigneusement orchestrée
ils sont emmenés dans une classe où l'on
enseigne le mandarin et les lois
chinoises et là on leur permet de poser
quelques questions sous l'oeil attentif
des agents du gouvernement
[Musique]
il était toujours en train de regarder
leur pop pour s'assurer qu'ils
répondaient correctement
j'ai enfin décidé de les questionner je
leur ai demandé leur nom et pourquoi ils
étaient là
il voulait qu'on propage une histoire
fabriquée de toutes pièces auprès de la
communauté internationale
selon laquelle il n'y a pas de camps de
concentration en chine ni de persécution
en raison de l'adhésion à l'islam ou de
l'origine ethnique en quelques clics
révélateur chang-dong démontre
l'absurdité de l'effort de propagande
chinois dans un camp de kashgar il a
découvert que juste avant la visite des
journalistes et des diplomates étrangers
les clôtures à my ont été remplacés par
des terrains de basket board
voici les images qu la chine souhaite
montrer au reste de la planète
des images tournées par la bbc lors
d'une visite guidée dans le même camp
ces jeunes jouent sur un terrain de
basket ball qui était inexistant
auparavant
le discours officiel de la chine est
aussi contredit par des témoignages
bouleversants de ouigours en exil qui
disent avoir vécu l'enfer des camps zoom
rideout dit avoir été interné et
endoctrinée pendant trois mois en classe
on nous parlait du parti communiste on
nous disait que nous étions perverti par
l'islam que c'était une maladie
contagieuse venant de l'étranger
ça rigole ça utb et une musulmane des
minorités kazakh dit avoir été emmenée
de force dans un camp pour enseigner le
mandarin aux détenus elle s'est confiée
à nos collègues de télévision publique
suédoise svt
donc si plusieurs personnes dormaient
dans un mètre carré elle devait dormir
sur leur côté droit sans bouger si elle
bougeait on les punit c'est bon pour ton
la table ronde autour d'un seul on serra
gaulle
il y avait une pièce appelée la chambre
noire où elle a été battue était détenu
en sortait parfois couverts de sang avec
les ongles arrachés
tous les cas il y avait une chaise avec
des clous pointé vers le haut et aussi
une autre chaise une chaise noire
il appelait la chaise du tigre tokyo
elle infliger des chocs électriques
tous les soirs nous pouvions entendre
des gens crier
c'était comme si on était torturé selon
ces ragots les femmes internées était
régulièrement agressés par des policiers
un souvenirs la hantent un viol qui
aurait été commis devant les détenus
n'ont ni joue-t-il ce serait rageant une
première étape c'était horrifiant il
avait rassemblé plus d'une centaine de
personnes et ils ont pris une jeune
femme dans la vingtaine les détenus
mariés ou célibataires étaient
sexuellement torturés tous les jours on
voyait de nos propres yeux des choses
horrifiante ce ne sont pas des êtres
humains
[Musique]
malgré la tension croissante à ce qui se
passe au xinjiang
la chine semble malgré tout déterminé à
poursuivre son programme de détentions
et d'assimilation forcée
la réaction de la communauté
internationale est trop timide
convalescent franqueville je crois que
la diplomatie discrète comme on
l'appelle ne fonctionne pas n'a pas fait
ses preuves et qu'aujourd'hui elles
mêmes complices de ce qui se passe
harki aliev lui espère que la communauté
internationale y compris canada répondra
à l'appel de détresse lancé par son
peuple
tout le monde est à fleur de peau ici
parce qu'on n'a aucune idée de ce qui
arrive à nos proches sont vivants son
support est ce qu'ils sont dans les
camps de concentration présentement en
train de souffrir là bas on n'a aucune
idée
[Musique]
il